that snow in the mountains visible from
the valley many people already headed
there to get a peek joe moeller gives us
a look at what you can expect if you
plan to go this weekend
after a pretty dry november people up
here in mount charleston say it was nice
to wake up to some snow now it's not
very much but people say it is making
them excited for winter when storms drop
snow in the higher elevations people
want to get a peek and have some fun
many would come up for the lodge but it
burned down in september this is the
first winter with it not being here
thomas schneckloff
of charleston lodge and cabin says he
wants people to know the cabins are
still open and he's excited for more
snow to come the visitor
volume to kyle canyon has been reduced
because we were the
number one attraction you know and uh so
we've definitely seen a change in
changing traffic on this side of the
mountain for this time of year but we'll
see if that all changes next week with
that storm coming in he says they have
plans for the winter to bring people's
favorite hot chocolate back he says with
the weekend here people can come up and
enjoy the snow and the trails while
there might not be enough snow to bust
out the sled it's still enough to come
up here and have some fun if you do you
are urged to take your trash and your
belongings with you back down the
mountain reporting on mount charleston
joe mohler live local now